hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions on the
Star Wars trailer this is going to be my
Q&A for that as well as my huge thank
you for 500k seriously I cannot thank
you guys enough for how awesome you've
been you have no idea what a dream come
true it is that I actually get to make
youtube videos for a living thank you
everyone for just spending your free
time talking about movie and TVs with me
it's utter and complete nonsense I just
cannot think of a better way to spend
the rest of my life so here's to the
next 500 k thank you so much to all the
people who found me when I had one
subscriber or the people that just found
me yesterday now let us talk about some
Star Wars so big news we actually got
some questions answered official
questions answered since the trailers
come out most notably like who some of
the people in the trailer words that
weren't immediately recognizable
specifically the really evil sounding
voice it actually ended up being Andy
Serkis which is a bit of a surprise
because the boy sounds nothing like them
I'll talk a little bit about him as we
get into rumors and spoilers at the end
of the video I will just say lights for
the warning now i will speak about a few
of the rumors just as i get into a
couple of the questions but i will do
like a section at the end where i'll
talk about some of the bigger rumor so
i'll say spoiler warning again when i
break it to that here we go the question
number one shinobu key jazz do you think
they'll have a Jedi Council rebuilt by
Luke in this timeline not like we saw in
the prequels but this is actually where
the first big rumor comes in there is a
British actor that has Star Wars Episode
7 listed on his CV and he's written down
the role of Padawan so if there's a
Padawan in the movie and it's not like a
dark Pat one like it's not a situation
there has to be some sort of Academy
situation happening whether or not
there's a lot of them remains to be seen
his name is Sam car there are actually a
number of actors that were revealed as
star wars 7 cast members based on this
CV listing is from this place called
spotlight UK I don't know if there's any
truth to it but if there's a bunch of
actors listing Star Wars Episode 7 on
their CV and if no one's professionally
slapping them in the face for lying
about episode 7 then it means it's
probably true question number two
datalore forever ass aren't all
stormtroopers clones that's actually
good question i saw a lot of confusion
about this no not all of them are clones
so part of the reason that rebels exists
like the Star Wars rebels cartoon is to
set the stage for the galaxy and some of
the ideas that we're going to see
the new trilogy even though the series
takes place you know way way in the past
if you saw that episode there was an
episode with Ezra Bridger joining the
Imperial Academy like right around the
time of rebels the empire starts taking
recruits again so that by the time of
the original trilogy you know episodes 4
5 and 6 most of those stormtroopers are
actually regular people that they've
just recruited for the most part I think
the clones are said to have died out
during the wars I'm sure there's still
some floating around but when you see
like legions of stormtroopers most of
them are recruits that are trained
question number 3 deaconess it's a trap
planet you say you think they're on mon
calamari that's one of the better rumors
I've seen like they were filming on an
island in a lake so of all the places
that they could possibly be visiting
like all the planets in episode 7 here
are some of the places that they've
filmed so the place that I was talking
about you know it's a trap yes Mon
Calamari they filmed at Ireland Skellig
Michael that's the place that everybody
thinks could be Mon Calamari just
because they've filmed on this really
tiny island that could have been the
entrance to this undersea living area it
could also been the place in the trailer
we saw those x-wings flying over that
big lake I've seen some rumors that one
of the original cast members could be
living there but they're a little
far-fetched so I'm not going to get too
deep into it but some of the other
filming locations were Tunisia and Abu
Dhabi in addition to Pinewood Studios in
London of course personally really
excited to c mon calamari though if that
ends up being true question for wizard
of warlocks ass the Dark Jedi looks like
a female I mean it's really thin looking
figure it could be a couple of
characters though we've already know
that Adam driver is going to be the
villain in the movie but he's not going
to be the only bad person we do know
there's not going to be a giant group of
Sid so this person is probably going to
be the obvious villain that we see like
the Darth Vader type character and that
Andy Serkis might be that big big
character in the shadows that won't
service till episode 8 and 9 he is the
voice-over of the trailer so I think of
you know this character that we're
seeing with the lightsaber is existing
in a relationship to Andy Serkis as
Darth Vader and the Emperor did in the
original trilogy in the prequels the
reason that everyone thinks that it
might be Brienne of Tarth Gwendoline
Christie I just think of her as bran all
the time is because of the way she's
walking like it's just very similar to
this game of thrones scene so I'll just
actually play this jiff while I'm
talking about this
I mean it could be Adam driver because
he is one of the villains it could also
be domhnall gleeson he's rumored to be
one of the antagonist to not the main
villain but one of the antagonist but I
do think that it is one of the new cast
members my ads are on Gwendoline
Christie or Adam driver though I just
really love the idea of an evil Brienne
of Tarth question 5 Jake ass would you
consider doing a video on the events of
the clone wars cartoon like a bonus
video I'm totally open to stuff like
that feel free if you have any requests
about old stuff please leave them in the
comments the Clone Wars has like such
this big history and I kind of skipped
over it like I wasn't like a big Clone
Wars fan while it was on like towards
the end I did kind of jump on the
bandwagon I haven't watched the Lost
missions yet but I'm totally open to
doing bonus videos for it most of the
videos i do will focus on the movies but
I do kind of want to get into expanded
canon I've really enjoyed doing rebels
videos it hasn't quite lived up to what
I wanted it to be but that's okay i mean
i have really high expectations for Star
Wars series so next year I'll start
focusing on more movie and expanded
canon videos remember the technically
the only things that are being
considered as canon are like the new
animated series the new books the new
comics there are a few aspects from
clone wars that there including in the
canon but you know technically it's it's
all the new stuff since disney bought
them so i'll try to get into the new
novels but it is always fun to look back
at the old stuff question 6 mg player s
the forest moon of Endor of course yeah
so that means we going to see he walks
again well not necessarily it is
interesting to think that we could go
back to Endor I mean we're gonna have to
see like a couple of familiar places in
addition to all the new planets will
visit I can just see like Disney's story
team and JJ Abrams getting really
excited to show these familiar places
that all the fans know about and twist
them and really unusual ways the idea
that end or maybe going through some
sort of like nuclear winter is pretty
crazy I think in that situation all the
Ewoks would be dead though as ingenious
as they are able to mount a complete
offensive against the Empire in under an
hour I don't think that they would be
able to survive a nuclear winter I have
seen some rumors about why this
character in particular is on Endor
think about what happened in return to
the Jedi and what might have been left
there like really notorious items that
might have been left there supposedly he
is there to find them I think there was
also a story in the expanded universe
that dealt with that
I think it's from Kevin J Anderson's
Jedi Academy trilogy I think that's when
that story took place it's been a long
time since I've read those novels that
was like the next trilogy that came
after the thrawn trilogy I would
actually say of like of all the novels
that came out like all the expanding
universe novels Thrawn Trilogy still in
my mind the best then the chemin j
anderson jedi academy trilogy that was
when Luke Skywalker started established
the Academy on Yavin but yeah I don't
think that we're gonna see e walks again
we'll probably get some sort of
reference some sort of visual reference
to e walks I cannot wait till Star Wars
Celebration I can only imagine the
amount of questions that are going to be
asked about the movie so this detail
like the Ewok detail will definitely
come out before the movie I would expect
it to be on the level of easter egg like
you know something buried in some of the
frames somewhere question number 7
Christopher asks what's up with the
astromech droids head on the soccer ball
why I mean we don't know that it's an
astromech droid but it's rumored to be
the droid built by daisy ridley that the
character we see on Tatooine no idea
what its purpose is other than being a
companion or scoping out salvage sites
but this is supposed to belong to Daisy
Ridley and it does look like it's on
Tatooine it does seem like they're
trying to turn it into a character on
the level of art too although I don't
think that anything is ever going to be
a character on the level of our to other
than Threepio that is or the bounty
hunter troy it's like ig-88 I'm actually
surprised that we haven't seen any of
those but I'm sure in some of the future
footage that they roll out we might see
some cybernetic life cybernetic forms of
life Pitino between droids and cyborgs
the interesting thing about that dry
though is that like its control unit
seems like it's magnetically attached to
the ball itself like the soccer ball or
whatever you want to call it it is an
interesting idea i mean it would give it
you know much more maneuverability
question 8 keygen ass could you do a
video about lightsabers in the force in
general and then how it's going to be
related to the movies and the characters
yeah I'm totally open to any ideas for
other bonus videos I mean for specific
bonus videos are probably what I'm most
interested in so yes totally like I said
it might break down the force one of the
most interesting things in terms of lore
Jedi lore especially like Knights of the
Old Republic like all the comics and
stuff really got deep into that who
knows how much of that they're going to
completely rewrite hopefully they don't
completely trash at all because some of
it is really really interesting I'm
totally open to that whenever I do bonus
videos for stuff like that though I will
specify like they
is where this information comes from it
might be thrown out it might be
completely different in the new trilogy
so even though Lucasfilm and Disney
aren't really thinking about it
specifically we can still talk about it
Jedi Laura was like a really important
part of my enjoyment of the franchise
and generally the video games as well as
the comics in the books so I'll man i'll
continue to talk about it question
number 9 luis s do you know for sure is
a dark jedi and not a sip yeah so you're
talking about that character no i mean
we don't know specifically if it's it
dark jedi or one of the inquisitors i'm
actually more inclined to think that
it's one of the new quisitor 'he's i
mean it's either one of the new
inquisitors or it is like the new main
character that's going to take on the
darth vader type role which would make
it either a Fallen Jedi or a sip they
spent all this time in Star Wars rebels
setting up the idea of inquisitors i
believe the inquisitors are going to be
very important to the new trilogy like
that's why they're laying all this
groundwork and rebels now it's like a
back door around the rule of two so like
you can have characters the wheeled
lightsabers but they don't necessarily
have the level of training or the
indoctrination of Sith characters it's
rumored that gwendoline christie is
actually going to be one of those type
of characters like she's not going to be
as if should be part of the empire but
she will be one of the inquisitors and
they're the group that's kind of roaming
around the galaxy chasing people down
like they fill the vacuum left by Vader
in the Emperor's death just in general
like in terms of rebels think about the
big things that you see like the way the
Empire's organized its relationship to
the rest of the galaxy like that's what
things are going to look like in the new
trilogy question number 10 book book s
the x-wings flying over the lake reminds
me of the greatest star wars video game
Rogue Squadron yes that was an awesome
video game Rogue Squadron took place
after episode 4 the spin-off movie red
five when is that going to take place
episode eight or nine well we don't
really know when it's going to take
place it's rumored to actually be one of
the earlier spin-off movies so
presumably it would take place sometime
after episode 7 yeah one of the things
I'm really looking forward to in episode
7 is them setting the stage for what all
these spin-off movies are going to be I
think some of the spin-off movies won't
occur concurrently with the new trilogy
some of them might be prequels but I do
think this x-wing movie will be set like
during the time of the new trilogy that
is of course assuming that it will be an
x-wing movie the Rogue Squadron novels
were actually a big part of the expanded
universe so if fans are that interested
and looking into the lives of rebel
pilots then I think that they would
totally turn that into a movie at least
in the new Canon which is why they're
calling it read five instead of rogue
five and yes that character is Oscar
Isaac but that doesn't necessarily mean
that he's going to show up in that red
five movie question 11 shane s man
you're always talking about Legend of
Korra I'm curious Charlie and what
ordered your favorite if you had to pick
between game of thrones star wars or
korra if you had a drop one what would
it be i mean in terms of favorite I mean
Star Wars is my original fandom like
when I was growing up that was like the
first thing I was a fan of right now
though I mean yeah Game of Thrones does
dominate a lot of my mind but Korra is
ending so I would say most of my
attention is on core right now actually
because Game of Thrones hasn't gotten
started yet like season five isn't here
the thing that's always biggest on my
mind just rotates to whatever is
actually happening currently I think the
only way that I would drop like one of
those things is if I had like so many
things to do that I wanted to like blow
my brains out question 12 Daniel ass
will Boba Fett or some other
Mandalorians be in the new movies I mean
I would say definitely yeah I mean if
they're in the rebels cartoon they're
definitely going to be in the new movie
in some way in case you guys have you
been watching rebels the character
Sabine rent is a Mandalorian in terms of
the spin-off movies I mean if we do get
a boba fett movie he there still has to
be alive or he has to be like on his
last legs thank you so much everyone for
submitting questions those are always a
ton of fun to do and congratulations to
the new giveaway winner foz bros i
totally love that name just reach out to
me on my channel for details you win at
win a dollar amazon gift card so here we
get into some of the bigger rumors about
the film so I'm just going to put this
spoiler tag up while I talk about it
remember these are all just rumors all
unconformity so if you all know ryan
Johnson was chosen to write in direct
episode 8 and he'll be working on
episode 92 but I don't think that he's
doing both writing and directing on that
film so supposedly Luke Skywalker is
going to be like Joseph gordon-levitt
and Bruce Willis's character from looper
at least in relation to the Rainmaker
without spoiling that film completely
just think about the Rainmaker character
and how he appears in the film like how
we meet him and what Bruce Willis and
Joseph gordon-levitt feel like they have
to do for a certain part of the film
that's rumored to be what puts Luke in
opposition to the other original cast
members again just a rumor but if it's
true it'd be pretty amazing that's why
it's possible that that red lightsaber
wildung character could be the Rainmaker
type character of this new trilogy but
part of the arc of episode 7 will be the
rise of that character and I just
realized that I forgot to mention it
during my questions but that lightsaber
is called a crossguard lightsaber the
reason it looks that way is because it's
designed to be that way by this if but
if the rainmaker type rumors are true
it's also possible that that character
could be just learning about the dark
side of the force and so they could be
inexperienced in this building you know
a less wieldy lightsaber the other
reason for the crossguard being that
it's supposedly supposed to keep you
from having an empire strikes back
situation where another Jedi can slice
your hand off for my next bonus video I
think because you guys requested I'll do
my favorite Jedi stories from the
expanded universe so that's going to
deepen two nights the Old Republic all
across the previous expanded universe
that would just kind of been thrown out
now i'll be sure to specify that
whenever I post it but be sure to
subscribe to get everything and again
feel free to leave all your requests for
any bonus videos that you want to see
just a quick reminder new mobile links
up here free on your mobile phone or on
your tablet you can now click on those
it's the same as the links that I had
over here but right now click here to
watch the trailer again maybe like ten
more times and click here for the latest
game of thrones viral teaser it's like
nine seconds of footage but it's like
the first game of thrones season five
trailer we've gotten so thank you so
much for watching so that's all high
five I'll see you guys tonight